[Musik]
er wollte unternehmen mit dem flute
klebt flüge als hans krieger vor fast 80
jahren war der schweizer armee das
bedrohten handwerk lernte waren die
flugzeuge noch aus holz und stoff gebaut
[Musik]
die holzpfähle wurden von knatternden
motoren angetrieben
100 jahre alt ist anzeiger heute und ist
einer der letzten zeitzeugen die den
zweiten wirklich als erwachsene gelebt
haben
woran erinnert er sich und decken sich
seine erinnerungen mit dem gängigen
geschichtsbild von jener zeit davon
handelt dieser film
[Musik]
hans giger hat weltgeschichte erlebt
aber auch die unglaubliche entwicklung
der technik der faszination des fliegens
anlage schon als kleiner bub bin ein bub
vom st galler oberland und wir sehen
viel fleisch kaffee und dann sind die
ersten piloten damals wut über darf noch
meyerfeldt oder nach hoch geflogen und
dann habe ich die erste die flüge und
natürlich festgelegt hat
weilburg war setzten sich hans giger und
seine schulfreunde zum ersten mal der
aerodynamik aus welche natürlich immer
auch buhrufe futter dieser spielplatz
und den freunden geburt zur felswand und
immer wenn der 50.000 unternehmer
approbierte zypern auf zur und schützen
aus der hand von der fels onkel und und
so schlägt der film mit musik selber in
der hand so der umlagerten denn in der
sekundarschule einen die meisten schüler
natürlich wieder lokomotiv führen würde
und das ist nicht gut
ansgar wurde militärpilot und besuchte
später auch das technikum die
technikbegeisterten noch immer
heute schreibt er auf dem computer
chroniken der schweizer luftfahrt und
gestaltet powerpoint präsentationen auch
mit seiner umwelt kommunizierte digital
da ist ja wunderbar mit den e mailen wie
man karriere mitte liegt und wir sind ja
nicht ganz
bis ja bis nicht wahr ist
seit zwei jahren verzichtet der
hundertjährige aufs autofahren nicht
ganz freiwillig er gegen das altern ein
handy das kafka
vor vier jahren hatte ich das kauft und
zwei jahren noch anhängig müsse abhilfe
machen vom wachstums und wirklichkeit
haben sie mehr spiele techno mit
begründung in dem alter fragt man im
auto was haben sie gemacht wenn sie im
bereich gegangen
mit dem turnier und einseitig war ja
nicht so dass ich ohne die wirklich
mittelrhein dalai lama ich muss keine
ins tor von servette unternehmer im
internet die adresse von der firma in
ebikon der carlo vertriebe dort wir
sehen aber nach edeka einkauft und sie
dann bin ich glücklich mit dem kanäle
und jetzt fahren sie mit dem wagen
[Musik]
anstiege unterwegs zum flugplatz buochs
wo er jahrzehntelang den fach gemessen
unterhalt der schweizer kam
flugzeugflotte garantierte auf dem
höhepunkt seiner karriere war er herr
über alle militärflugplätze mit über
3.000 mitarbeitern
[Applaus]
in burg starten heute die fabrik neun
pilatus flugzeuge der stanser
flugzeugwerke
anstiege wohnt seit 67 jahren hier am
ende der fluggäste
[Applaus]
1939 wurde das damals bescheidene
flugfeld nach kriegsbeginn schnell zu
einem logistischen zentrum ausgebaut
gegner war damals junge offizier dabei
dann ich rieche programm los gange und
material an die wiener die schwierig
sehr zäh der abbruch führten die
besucher winterlager für die werkstätten
aufbaue
über die einladung der flugplatz
direktion zu einer spritztour mit einem
sportflieger rund um den bürgenstock
freut sich der veteran nur zögerlich
schließlich habe er sein halbes leben im
cockpit verbracht
hoch über dem see und in bergen kommen
die erinnerungen an damals im hölzernen
zweisitzer das einmaleins des fliegens
lernte
doch bis anstiege in ein flugzeug
steigen konnte musste er am flugplatz
dübendorf erst eine lehre als
flugzeugmechaniker absolvieren
der weg ins cockpit führte damals über
die werkstatt 50 senatoren aus holz
wertstoffe erde
das war in den frühen 30er jahren als in
deutschland hitler an die macht kam
wenn handys ist man vom hitler gehört ja
also körper nicht an der schule
münster natürlich bin ich riesig
werkzeug sie haben leere grossmann kreis
und seine städte hitler sich ganze
wollte und der härter werk schüler zeigt
was das ist passiert bemüht er hat mein
kampf gläser kann mir noch nicht mehr
junge baustein der karnickel was politik
und seine von der national league wird
er es zählt was dir den willen nach und
ist erstmals erzählt dass er wählen
armee aufbauen was er will
zum relaunch ausziehen das hat er alles
geben um ein komplott
aber das nicht so macht aber ein
besonderer typ sicher herr großmann der
klassik lachen etwa 1600 hans giger als
junger offizier nach der lehre folgt die
rekruten dann die offiziersschule mit
der pilotenausbildung
ihr büffelte 21-jährige theorie
motorentechnik aerodynamik bei der
gründe
[Musik]
dann die ausbildung mit den fluglehrern
ganz genau erinnert sich der pionier
also zum ersten mal das flugzeug allein
gesteuert
irgendwann hat der lehrer einem
durchführte bezeichnete doppelstöcker
als und nun ein zeichen dass man sie
hätte ich mir leid
die ausbildung zum militärpiloten es
geschafft die freude groß doch in europa
herrscht kriegsangst bald werden die
jungen piloten das gelernte anwenden
müssen
die schweizer armee macht sich bereit
für die kriegs mobilmachung im
jungpiloten kommt eine besondere aufgabe
zu das ist die flugzeug voll gestopft
mit mobil mache ich staccato berät
gemüse in die hinterste alpentäler
abwerfen
nach dem überfall hitlers auf polen ist
die kriegs mobilmachung in der schweiz
in form gang 430.000 man leisten sofort
den fahneneid dem aufgebot haben ferner
42 1000 pferde und 12.000 zivile motor
fahrzeuge zu folgen
die armee macht sich an den bau von
geschütz stellungen und
grenzbefestigungen
hans giger repariert während des krieges
mit seinen leuten havarierte flugzeuge
die er als werks beruht dann auch selber
testet in den ersten kriegsjahren leiste
der auf vielen militärflugplätzen in der
ganzen schweiz dienst auch auf dem
flugplatz losern der hangar aus den 20er
jahren sind heute noch gleich aus wie
damals die zeit in der westschweiz wird
ansgar nie mehr vergessen company 2 auf
lausanne bevor wir wollten ein menge
stark und nach geschafft denn die stadt
flächen ihre flugzeug wieder braucht und
zwar einige male im sommer bei schönem
wetter gehen wir mit der mannschaft ins
spiel rief blass aber gattin und bitte
gleichzeitig sehe wie schädlich mal wird
das sehe hat gm manager von das ist aber
sie messen oder schönheit definitives
infrage aber wir müssen vor steht er mit
einer für ihn er hat mich im heim mutter
[Musik]
was kann ich als die mutter berichtet 32
blieb durch los sein schuss adrenalin
fluss sein um kämpfer hier nur rote
tüten der stolze offizier und die
schaffhauserin aline am hochzeitstag rcg
und zieht rufen alle wochen urlaub
machen und dann eine frau und ihr pferd
in alswede kursteilnehmer tut macht vor
wie das wiener kirche folge oberhalb
andermatt erst mal übernachtet und noch
mehr über der oberhalb nachhol von nas
zu mehrheiten haben so maxi wo mehrere
vor anderen gelaufen sind
der regen oberhalb von short sache des
lee congerton eines sammlers ins ausland
und super league
die düsteren vorahnungen für
schaffhausen sollten sich bewahrheiten
amerikanische flugzeuge bombardieren die
stadt ihr ziemlich 38 menschen sterben
ein haus von allerdings familie wird
beschädigt
gegen elf uhr morgens nach
amerikanischer bomber staffeln brand und
sprengbomben ab schaffhausen ab vom
rheinufer bis zum bahnhof den
stadtzentrum und im südlichen viertel
entstanden beträchtliche schäden
[Musik]
die schweizer luftwaffe ist die einzige
waffengattung der schweizer armee die
während des krieges aktiv in
kampfhandlungen verwickelt wird
flugzeuge aller kriegsparteien dringen
in den schweizer luftraum heim
[Musik]
diese wichtige episode des krieges
wollen wir mit hans giger im flieger
museum dübendorf diskutieren
anstiege gehört zu den gründervätern des
museums
der historiker jakob tanner hat sich
intensiv mit den einsätzen der schweizer
luft stoffe beschäftigt und das hat kann
das ist bei der tg vögel wie ddr einst
zeitzeugen sind für ihn eine wichtige
quelle noch ein wechsel hans giger
begegnet historikern mit einem gesunden
maß an misstrauen das ist doch wie
kritisch die historiker sie jetzt aber
er bringt aber schon ich verweise laptop
wenn sein dritter überbelichtet anders
schaut sich ihnen in den weg
das ist probleme wenn sie das problem
dass
gibt es das die story kritischen
natürlich mehr details workers 170 ps
schilderte sie dass dennoch der aber zum
beispiel so werd ichs frage dreht ja wir
hätten wir zum beispiel richtet neue
betriebsgebäude macht trip vom hitler
der schweizerische press dann bin ich
als historiker informiert dass die
meisten durchaus perspektive gesehen
dass man noch hinein filz positiv
darüber berichtet
und wenn eine zügige seiten nicht denken
geht es natürlich vom historiker
weiteres problem in den ersten
kriegsmonaten im die schweizer luft war
für den grenzschutz ernst und sie
bekämpft wollte einzelne schweizer
piloten schießen elf deutsche maschinen
ab nazi deutschland ist außer sich war
gibt die schweiz nach verschiedene
befällt die einmal hat man zeit mit dem
flugzeug wo fünf kilometern flüge den
chip mit bekämpfen
das sind einfach ein pilotenfehler
wollen rang nach den oder über wird
bringt das hätte zurückführt dass
deutschland enorm geht schweiz
propagandistisch mobilisiert hat die
handwerker sabotiere die aktion ist aber
so dilettantisch teure führt sie dass
sie sofort ruft flogen ist monika
ausrichter und dann hätten wir in der
schweiz und zwanzigster juni der
neutralität schutz verboten
das heißt schweizer flüge hatten immer
dürfen kempter sie einander täufer zu
möglichst zwei aufstiegen
gegen ende des krieges landen in der
schweiz dutzende amerikanische bomber
viele wurden über deutschland
angeschossen und flüchteten über die
grenze in dübendorf werden die pflege in
reih und glied gestellt doch auch
deutsche flugzeuge landen in dübendorf
in dieser streng geheime messerschmidt
düsenjäger das weltweit erste flugzeug
dieser art schweizer ingenieure und
militärs begutachten den flieger mit
großem interesse
auch ansgar war bei einem test des
triebwerks dabei das laufen und hat ihre
für straße in den usa und in riesa lärm
und die gewissheit alles messe genauso
geheim ist die mt 110 das erste flugzeug
das mit radar ausgerüstet war die
landung in der schweiz ist ein schock
für die deutschen
die schräge kann ohne karte steht bald
die kanone und hofer chance hin mit dem
ich in die tücher und bumberger und in
den vorort pumpe chance die deutschen
verlangen von der schweiz die sofortige
herausgabe ihrer fliegenden wunderwaffe
oder deren zerstörung
1 gg ist dabei als das flugzeug in
dübendorf bei nacht und nebel gesprengt
wird
mit einer verwegen ist mit der
handlichen das schweiz das flugzeug
springt unter deutscher aufsicht also
diesen fragen und handwerk wird
gleichzeitig mit zwölf meister schmidt
wo man doch sehr viel zahlte million pro
stück die deutschen hatten den
schweizern schrott flugzeuge verkauft
kaum haben wir die flugzeugbetreiber
notwendige paar 2 und eine ganz schlimme
und die motoren untersucht doch nicht g
das stupa locker sehen dass alles so
schmutzig da hätten alle motoren
untersucht und hätte dass ich nicht
reparierbar china so schlecht montiert
dass mir das nicht noch an verantwortet
flugzeug abschiebe samt motoren
[Musik]
heute lebt hans giger alleine im haus am
see wo fünf jahren ist seine frau aline
nach 68 jahren gestorben
was rät der 100 jährige seinen enkeln
und urenkeln liebe beschied ihn
interessiert was passiert um hunger und
freundlich so anna lüth und dann
selbstverständlich später wünsche dass
sie sich auch betätigen geistig und
körperlich und maßhalten im essen
trinken rauchen also drei land wieder
die
[Musik]
acht urenkel hat hans giger heute oft
kommen sie am wochenende und werden
ferien zu besuch als groß und
urgroßvater verschont hans gegen seine
familie mit den üblichen aktivdienst
anekdoten außerdem schwierig erzählt sie
nein dabei vermeidet er hat vor allem
immer wieder erwähnt im strandbad uschi
müller st die als hübsche badenixen eine
richtige wachs oder wiener sie dann
angesprochen hat vorhin mit dem finger
auf schulter geklopft und gesagt eine
frau die mit mehrkosten selbst gesagt
[Musik]